[Applause]
all those years of wisdom
and compassion
we've been so so lucky
her work ethic
her strong faith her leadership
there wasn't anything imagined he
couldn't do
there was a courtesy
and a humanity
and a kindness
that i'll remember forever
it was a life of public service and duty
[Music]
committed her country
[Music]
my lords and members of the house of
commons
i pray that the blessing of almighty god
may rest upon your councils
and her commonwealth i feel enormously
proud of what the commonwealth has
achieved
and all of it within my lifetime
devoted wife and mother
a constant figure of national pride
as the world around her witnessed
extraordinary change
[Applause]
born in 1926 princess elizabeth wasn't
expected to be queen
home videos show it was a happy
childhood
in those days it was such wonderfully
unorganized fun because i mean we played
a game called catching happy days which
involved rolling around the garden at
great speed catching the leaves as they
fell off the trees
that kept us happy all day
her destiny changed with the death of
her grandfather and the abdication of
her uncle
[Music]
her father was now king and elizabeth
his heir her role for life was set and
her approach to it shaped by the second
world war clear even in her first
broadcast when she was evacuated to
windsor
my sister margaret rose and i feel so
much for you
as we know from experience what it means
to be away from those we love most of
all
the keep calm carry on
philosophy
was absolutely embedded in
in her i think the princess became a
member of the ats
she joined the auxiliary territorial
service as others went off to fight
lieutenant mountbatten seems bad to be
back at work again wartime also sparked
the most important relationship of her
life
she kept in touch with prince philip by
writing letters
[Music]
and in 1947 they got engaged
[Music]
a glamorous young couple their wedding
was celebrated across the country
soon prince charles was born followed by
princess anne they're taking the places
of the king and queen who would have
gone but for his majesty's owners
but judy called her father was ill and
they had to take his place on a tour of
the commonwealth
to the stunned heart of london and to
the whole commonwealth came the tragic
news from sandringham of the passing of
a beloved sovereign king george vi
in a remote lodge in kenya prince philip
told her the news she was now queen
all accounts say that she gulped
gathered herself
a grieving daughter but also now the
queen
in a way that she could never have
imagined and of course in her early 20s
at the time
the following year came her coronation
broadcast for the first time on
television
she was very conscious of the fact that
she needed to be out there to be visible
going right back to televising the
coronation
only 26 queen elizabeth still had to
prove herself to courtier's politicians
and the country
years later she described how it felt
[Music]
in a way i didn't have an apprenticeship
my father died
much too young
it was all a very sudden kind of
taking on
and
making the best job you can
from the very start she felt she had to
get out and connect with the public the
queen and duke now took their places
through thousands of engagements and
inventing the walk bout whether you were
the lollipop lady
or you know you were a president or a
prime minister of a nation people become
nervous and it was wonderful to see how
her majesty
would put them at eat
always calm even when blanks were fired
at trooping the color
the queen was constantly on duty
with constitutional responsibilities
and weekly audiences with her prime
ministers
for someone who just who'd been a little
boy
in the streets of durham waving your
flag when she drove through in the 1960s
and suddenly they were your prime
minister
virtually alone
of all the people that you knew you knew
anything that you said to us stayed
within the room
always displaying her support for the
military
the principle
of listening to what she thought
churchill might have done in similar
conditions or circumstances to what i
found myself in it was those sort of
conversations that i learned a huge
amount from and we'll treasure forever
there's really nice comments including
one from president biden
oh that's very kind as every day there
were red boxes full of state papers to
deal with do we think that this is a
good idea do we not know what it's about
she was a wonderful boss we used to put
up a red box every evening and we knew
that she would have been through them
and it would be back on our desk
the next morning at eight o'clock
it was extraordinary how
she did this day after day throughout
her reign
[Music]
[Applause]
wasn't just matters at home as head of
the commonwealth and queen of other
realms
[Music]
she traveled more than any other head of
state i remember going to
uganda for the commonwealth heads of
government conference
and from the airport to the hotel
i don't think i've ever seen crowds like
it
always conducting her own powerful form
of soft diplomacy i did get a sense how
concerned she was sometimes about
some of the conflicts some of the
challenges
[Music]
she can have
a personal
conversation which
you know helps to move on
some really quite difficult and tricky
political moments
[Music]
they melt around her and i've seen the
strongest men just literally sort of
become putty in their fingers
they are all an aura fan
argus
the first british monarch to visit the
republic of ireland in a hundred years
she was a figurehead of unity and
stability
she never wavered from duty or service
and in uncertain times people need
anchors
we've lost one of our most important
anchors
i'm very glad to be able to join you
today there at times of national tragedy
including the coronavirus pandemic
adapting the way she worked
to reach out set an example
and rally the nation with messages of
resilience
we should take comfort that while we may
have more still to endure
better days will return
we will be with our friends again
we will be with our families again
we will meet again
majesty is the warrior queen she has
done it she's been there
and her majesty dressed the nation it's
the empathy we're all in this together
but it's going to be okay
my grandfather broadcast the first of
these christmas messages
her christmas broadcast every year was
her chance to send a personal message
it's no surprise
that families so often treasure their
christmas routines
because behind the formality was an
utterly devoted wife and mother
prince andrew five last february
probably feels quite senior now that he
has a baby brother
family is very close together and
and we do enjoy spending time and she's
always made time all the way through her
life and and yes there have been those
particular moments of the year when
that very much comes first
when we were very young obviously um it
was uh
it was harder for her to have so much
time and we were obviously living
elsewhere as well so we were never
really all together in the same place
but whenever we had the family moments
and we met up
she'd be very keen on watching what the
children were up to and
i think there were moments when she
loved the noise running around the house
it kind of brought the house to life and
it kind of made the real family
atmosphere i think they had to be strong
enough
[Music]
you see this is strong enough to
get off you know
while she was head of state phillip was
head of the family and a huge support
come around this side nasty feelings
they were a couple
with a different relationship than many
people have but he learnt to live with
that
and difficult to be a
monarch with
the degree of responsibility you have
without a very good partnership to back
you up
when there were tough moments
if he was around it was hugely important
you could see them working a crowd or
working a walkabout if you watch it
they'll stop you
it wasn't planned it was instinct
they both had the same metabolic clock i
think
in
2021 she said goodbye to her beloved
husband and dedicated consort
[Music]
we have been inspired by his unwavering
loyalty to our queen
what you see
is
courage
but also a complete lack of self-pity
she feels grief but
as she said on one occasion it's not
about me
in a less deferential world they did
weather more difficult times especially
in the 1990s as her children got
divorced and a fire wrecked windsor
castle
in the words of one of my more
sympathetic correspondence
it has turned out to be an anus
horribilis
in 1997 princess diana died in a car
crash
it was a low point for the royal family
as the crowds criticized them for
staying in scotland
[Applause]
the queen eventually decided to speak
i admired and respected her for her
energy and commitment to others
and especially for her devotion to her
two boys the queen's life has been a
continual process of
evaluation reevaluation
shaping how you keep him
in touch with a world that's changing
very fast but she was always doing that
in recent years the queen led the
monarchy through more turmoil with the
sussexes leaving
[Music]
and prince andrew facing sex abuse
allegations
she rarely showed emotion in public
privately she was known for her genuine
warmth and kindness
one of my predecessors said you never
come out of your morning session with
the queen feeling worse than when you
went in
she was always worried about you and how
you were
fighting people
yeah
we were up shooting one day up in
balmoral and the weather changed in the
afternoon so i took my raincoat i
wrapped it around i gave him my scarf
and my gloves
and and as i walked away
i cheekily took my flat shooting hat off
and put it on top of a head scarf
three weeks later she called me into her
office
and she'd had this photograph developed
and put in a beautiful frame for me and
she said i thought you'd like to keep
this as a souvenir of that very funny
afternoon we had up in the hills of
scotland just one poor
she was never happier than when she was
with her dogs and watching her horses
she does relax with racing poke yes
definitely
the queen when she gets the racing [ __ ]
you can see the shoulders drop
you can see it ah somebody i know
somebody i've got something common with
and she does maybe spend a little bit
longer with them
i do remember that suddenly there was a
huge fight going on amongst
a number of corgis
she waded in and she got bitten in the
process but she sorted it out
just sometimes we would see a glimpse of
her sense of humor what you wish for
really
please
boom
as she shared the screen with some of
britain's other biggest stars james bond
at the 2012 olympics the two figures
disappeared out of the helicopter harry
in complete incredulity just shouted out
go granny
and paddington bear for her platinum
jubilee i always keep on for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
for later
thank you
cool everything
that's very kind
[Music]
as the queen grew older the whole
country would come together to celebrate
her milestone moments
[Music]
she would go on to become britain's
longest reigning monarch
inevitably a long life can pass by many
milestones
my own is no exception
[Music]
[Applause]
and the first to mark a platinum jubilee
[Applause]
a family increasingly expected to step
in to support her
[Music]
the queen's remarkable reign and the
stability it brought helping to secure
the future of the monarchy as her family
continued to grow
[Music]
throughout her life honoring to the end
the pledge she made at just 21.
[Music]
i declare before you all
that my whole life whether it be long or
short shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you